how does the screenwriter know when it's
time to sell their screenplay
well you want to show it to a bunch of
friends you want to get notes from
friends who know screenwriting who know
movies and can give you know how to give
notes on a script so ideally you're in a
writers group and you've gotten feedback
from your writers group you've written I
would say at least five or six drafts
the writing is rewriting as we know and
hopefully maybe you've shown it to
someone who's in the industry not as a
submission but as a friend read where
they've given you some feedback so
there's really no way to know exactly
when you're going to be ready to bring
something to market but basically field
test it with as many people as you can
to the point where you feel like it's in
its best shape possible
okay let's suppose friends family say oh
this is excellent
now we know that they have their reasons
for saying it as well and they don't
want to hurt our feelings they want to
see us do well let's suppose we're ready
to try to go out there and take it to
market what are some of the first things
what are some websites that we can go to
well what can we do to try to help sell
it well I think you should make a hit
list of companies and people that you're
gonna send your script to I mean first
of all it's good to get a rep so you
want to send it to managers that accept
unsolicited submissions
I believe the writers guild has a list
of those there's a website called the
tracking board where you can probably
find some good manager lists but I
always say pick up the phone
that's the big thing now we don't make
as many phone calls as we used to it you
know it makes us all a little nervous
and if you're a skittish writer who's
more of an introvert that's tough but
you have to pick up the phone and you
can actually get submissions just from
cold calling and introducing yourself
and being nice and saying hey here's
what my scripts about here's the long
line do you want to read it now they may
shut you down right away and say we
don't accept any unsolicited submissions
but they may love it
and they can send you a waiver form that
you can sign to where you can submit
without a rep but that's only if they've
heard your logline they've heard your
pitch and they really like it and they
want to read it
you